[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa soy santiago lópez gonzález este
es el espacio de france 24 en que
hacemos un resumen de las noticias más
destacadas relacionadas con la pandemia
de kobe 19 a continuación los temas que
vamos a tratar en el programa de hoy
haremos énfasis en las nuevas variantes
que están preocupando a la organización
mundial de la salud la variante del está
detectada en la india que es 60% más
contagiosa según los reportes y que ya
está haciendo presencia en cerca de 70
países alrededor del mundo
hablaremos también de la llamada
variante andina que ya la habíamos
mencionado en programas en programas
anteriores pero en esta oportunidad
ampliaremos la información porque es
importante entender estas variantes en
momentos cuando muchos países están
comenzando su apertura social y
comercial después de muchos ires y
venires y rodó por fin el balón de la
copa américa que tiene lugar en brasil
en medio de muchas controversias por la
compleja situación sanitaria que está
viviendo ese país las elecciones y las
delegaciones de los diferentes países no
han escapado la pandemia más de 60
contagios que han sido de
después de cerca de 6000 pruebas
realizadas desde los directivos y
organizadores hasta los jugadores y los
colaboradores 60 casos entre ellos 27
futbolistas y la copa apenas está
comenzando veremos entonces cómo está la
situación y estará con nosotros el
doctor carlos eduardo pérez para nuestra
consulta vamos a tratar varios temas las
variantes la vacuna a curva que no
alcanzó los resultados satisfactorios
también la posible mezcla de vacunas
dentro de los esquemas de inmunización
una práctica que podría acelerar los
procesos de inoculación y también
hablaremos de nuevos protocolos que
llevan a una rápida recuperación de los
pacientes que están hospitalizados con
kobe 19 pues comenzamos y lo hacemos
entonces hablando de la organización
mundial de la salud que anunció que la
variante andina ahora denominada como
variante lambda pasa a ser denominada
como una variante de interés por tener
una mayor capacidad de transmisión del
cob y 19 según los reportes la variante
lambda representa ya la mayoría de los
casos de contagio que hay en perú y
también representa un alto
de los contagios en chile y en argentina
veamos
hasta el momento como variante andina
ahora la oms se la ha denominado como el
lambda no sólo es un cambio de nombre
lanza pasa ahora a considerarse como
variante de interés una denominación
bajo la que se encuentra en otras seis
variantes en todo el mundo primera y más
leve de las tres clases de variantes que
clasifica la o ms seguida de las
variantes preocupantes en última
instancia a la denominación alta
consecuencia que por el momento no
cuenta con ninguna variante registrada
blanda no es una variante nueva fue
detectada por primera vez en perú en
agosto de 2020 pero tras un largo
monitoreo la o ms señala su mayor
capacidad de transmisión comunitaria el
organismo estudia si lambda podría tener
mutaciones que la hacen más contagiosa y
resistente a los anticuerpos el campo de
acción de esta variante es
principalmente américa latina'
en perú la variante supone ya el 81 por
ciento de los casos monitoreados desde
abril en chile representa asimismo el 32
por ciento de los casos reportados en
los últimos 60 días similar a la
incidencia de la variante brasileña en
este país
argentina por su parte informó de una
incidencia del 37 por ciento entre el 2
de abril y el 19 de mayo ahora la oms se
deberá estudiar si lanza podría dar el
paso a variante de preocupación
hora de la consulta con el doctor carlos
eduardo pérez infectólogo y asesores de
científico de france 24 de doctores
gracias por estar con nosotros
nuevamente en el programa como siempre
un gusto y quiero que comencemos
hablando precisamente de las variantes
ya estamos mencionando la variante
lambda en el reportaje que salió hace
unos segundos pero hay otra variante que
está generando preocupación a nivel
mundial y también en lado ms y es la
variante delta que surgió precisamente
en febrero en índia y qué
características tiene ya que nos estamos
enfrentando con estas dos variantes
es muy importante santiago buenas noches
que las variantes significan pequeños
cambios o grandes cambios que se hacen
en las proteínas y hacen que el sistema
inmunológico pueda o no reconocer esta
nueva este nuevo cuasi especia viral
cuando se llama de intereses porque se
monitoriza y cuando es preocupante es
porque evidentemente se ha encontrado
una característica que hace que se
alerte mundialmente y que se hagan
ensayos para la vacunación o para los
tratamientos
la variante delta antes llamada variante
hindú esta variante ya es preocupante
porque su diseminación es muy efectiva y
al aumentar el número de casos
incrementa la mortalidad la variante
lambda es una variante de interés que se
está monitorizando y muy probablemente
si se documenta que la mortalidad se
relaciona a estos contagios y que la
situación que vemos en américa latina
pasará de ser de interés a ser
preocupante y se harán otros estudios
para evaluar
estas mutaciones estos cambios en el
virus doctores en otro tema
investigadores han dado a conocer esta
semana un tratamiento o un protocolo
usted me corregirá el término correcto a
nivel médico contra el kobe 19 que puede
salvar las vidas de las personas que
están siendo tratadas con esta
enfermedad y como funciona con
anticuerpos que se adhieren al virus
evitando que éste se duplique o que siga
contagiando infectando
sí es muy interesante este fue el
medicamento que usó donald trump cuando
tuvo su enfermedad sino que ya tenemos
la evidencia de los datos y las
aprobaciones que se están haciendo en el
mundo acerca de unos anticuerpos estos
anticuerpos son anticuerpos que son
capaces de neutralizar el virus lo que
se encontró recientemente es que
personas que tienen kobe y no tienen
presencia de anticuerpos cuando se le
administra este medicamento en este
protocolo investigación se encontró que
reduce la mortalidad a 28 días en una
forma significativa cuando a las
personas que no se les aplica pero no es
a todos los pacientes es a un grupo de
pacientes que no tengan anticuerpos este
es un paso muy importante porque
encontramos una herramienta efectiva
para disminuir la mortalidad la
vacunación el tratamiento efectivo será
lo que finalice la pandemia ya estamos
en proceso de vacunación y buscar un
tratamiento efectivo también hace parte
de el control de la pandemia es una
buena noticia
es hecho por el laboratorio rellenaron y
es comercializada en varias partes del
mundo por laboratorio de roche y
esperamos tener disponibilidad en
nuestra región para poderla ofrecer a
los pacientes aún así sigue siendo un
tratamiento muy costoso vale entre 1.400
y 2800 dólares
tener acceso a este tratamiento para
para poder minimizar un poco los los lo
que produce el kobe 19 en el organismo
estamos también doctor a la expectativa
del desarrollo de nuevas vacunas que
podrían llegar al mercado y había una en
alemania la curva que estaba generando
mucha expectativa estábamos ahí
esperando alguna respuesta y tal parece
que fracasó en una parte clave del
proceso de desarrollo y solamente
alcanza una eficacia del 47 por ciento
esto significa entonces que ya está
vacuna ya queda descartada no sirve o
puede ser utilizada digamos en algunos
de los protocolos o tratamientos o para
algunos casos particulares de kobe 19
esta es una pregunta muy interesante y
muy importante porque en américa latina
se llevaban varios países estudios
clínicos con esta vacuna lo primero esta
vacuna demostró una eficacia inferior al
50 por ciento del quenti dt por ciento
sobre todo en las variantes es de
circulación distinto a las vacunas de
mma que se han hecho en el año anterior
que tenía una circulación de virus
distinto esta fue retada con la con unos
linajes distintos y su eficacia pues no
es la esperada muy probablemente esto es
un análisis interino todas no son los
análisis definitivos en donde en este
por ejemplo cuando esta circulación de
estas linajes no se debía usar esta
vacuna pero está pendiente por
desarrollar otros análisis para mirar
eficacia tiempo es muy importante saber
que esta vacuna tiene que someterse a
una entidad regulatoria con los estudios
clínicos y son las entidades
regulatorias las que van a decir si se
sigue adelante con la aprobación o no
los estudios clínicos no fueron
satisfactorios y muy
solamente tendrán que reformular la
vacuna como ya lo están haciendo para
poder no ser inhibida por los linajes
que están circulando en la actualidad
doctor pérez nos consultaban algunos de
nuestros televidentes a través de las
redes sociales de france 24
sobre esos raros casos que se han
presentado también en los últimos días
de personas que se han contagiado de
kobe 19 que ya tenían las dos dosis de
la vacuna y han fallecido y han tenido
que padecer un hobbit fuerte con
hospitalización de varios días que
finalmente pues terminó en la muerte de
estos pacientes que dice la comunidad
científica que dicen los médicos sobre
estos casos que son poco comunes hago la
aclaración
santiago este es un punto muy importante
porque hemos hablado siempre que las
vacunas son seguras y eficaces pero
nunca hemos dicho 100%
efectivas la racionalidad decrece al 90
94 95 por ciento recordemos que es
cuando hablamos de una eficacia de 95%
estamos diciendo que cuando una persona
se vacuna reduce en un 95% la
probabilidad de tener complicaciones por
el coi hay un grupo de personas de
personas que han tenido la enfermedad
eso se ha documentado desde los estudios
clínicos y muy pocos casos han tenido
algún grado de severidad es
probablemente también en los linajes es
una explicación porque estas vacunas que
están diseñadas irritadas con unos
linajes que no se conocían sino que
actualmente es lo que está circulando
pudieran haber fracasado o puedan no ser
efectivas para controlar pero las
vacunas todas que tenemos disponibles
absolutamente todas las que tenemos
disponibles son activas
funciona incluso para las variantes pero
no son 100% eficaces por eso hasta que
no estemos vacunados todos tenemos que
mantener las medidas de bioseguridad
pero en la medida que se vaya incrementó
la incrementando la vacunación
disminuimos los linajes y habrá mayor
posibilidad de que las personas que se
infecten post vacunales pues sea mucho
menor estos casos son excepcionales esta
no es la regla en la excepción las
vacunas son seguras eficaces y por eso
debemos mantener la seguridad de todas
las vacunas y mantener la masificación
de la vacuna en toda nuestra región y el
llamado la invitación es a que la gente
aproveche los planes de vacunación y se
inmunice y también que siga cuidándose a
través del lavado de manos y el uso del
tapabocas doctor hemos visto la
disparidad también a nivel mundial en
cuanto a la recepción de lotes de
vacunación en muchos países están
planteando entonces la posibilidad de
mezclar las diferentes dosis
provenientes de diferentes farmacéuticas
para poder garantizar en las que
necesitan las segundas dosis la
inoculación que necesitan sus habitantes
para poder
el esquema esto puede tener algún
problema para el paciente puede servir
como una fórmula para acelerar la
inoculación en algunos países que se han
visto un poco rezagados para recibir los
lotes de vacunación porque han sido
acaparados por las grandes economías
si esta es una pregunta que ha surgido
desde el inicio se pueden mezclar las
vacunas lo más probable es que la
respuesta sea así en la actualidad hay
dos publicaciones relativamente
recientes en donde se han mezclado
vacunas de astrazéneca con vacunas de
spicer en donde se mostró por la
seguridad es decir no hacen daño y ya
hay algunos datos que muestran que
mejora la inmuno de la entidad
eso significa mejorar la capa hacia los
anticuerpos sin embargo los estudios
clínicos lo que hemos aprendido es tener
sensatez tiempo y paciencia para poder
entenderlos y desarrollarlos en su
tiempo para luego aplicarlo es probable
en la combinación de las vacunas sea una
de las herramientas que tengamos para
enfrentar el futuro o incluso para
reforzar inmunizaciones que ya tenemos
se utilicen plataformas distintas es muy
importante recordar que las vacunas son
seguras algunas personas temen dicen
bueno presione ponga uno u otro me va a
hacer daño lo que no sabemos es si va a
ser bien pero lo que definitivamente
está demostrado es que no hacendado
doctor y le transmito una de las
preguntas que también llegan a través de
las redes sociales está avanzando la
vacunación en américa latina' pero la
región sigue en esa larga meseta de
contagio las cifras no dan tregua o la
disminución es muy poca contrario a lo
que quisieran las autoridades o los
gobiernos de los diferentes países nos
estamos confiando estamos viendo las
variantes la apertura económica y social
la vacunación lenta el pico que no baja
estamos perdiendo la batalla como
analiza usted la situación
nosotros en la región de américa latina
somos en este momento así que no estamos
en toda la explosión de lo que ya no es
un pico sino una meseta y es realmente
en algunos países un desastre lo que se
está viendo en cuanto a la atención de
los pacientes distinto a lo que ha
pasado en europa en eeuu donde también
han sufrido incremento las ha llevado a
muchos fallecidos en este momento
estamos ante el contexto de una
enfermedad prevenible prevenible por una
vacuna y prohibir por las unidades de
seguridad en la región ha pasado que hay
una desigualdad social es patente lo
segundo es que después de vacunaciones
fueron tardíos y se están implementando
lentamente y esta circulación de la
variante lambda de la variante semana o
de la variante de eta y este tipo de
varias variantes también impactaron
porque incrementaron el número de casos
y además un sistema de frágil de salud
son muchos factores pero definitivamente
no vamos a perder la pata la batalla
vamos a salir adelante y vamos a tener
inmunidad muy probablemente al número de
infectados y no el número de vacunados
pero estamos pasando por la peor crisis
de la pandemia y eso es una realidad que
todos vemos y todos estamos sufriendo en
la actualidad doctor pérez pues como
siempre un gusto conversar con usted nos
aclara todas las dudas y también nos
pone en actualización con varios temas y
nos explica en detalle qué es lo que
está sucediendo referente a las vacunas
ya los procesos de vacunación muchas
gracias por estar con nosotros bueno y
ahora veamos algunas cifras así cierra
la semana la vacunación en américa
latina' veamos algunos países de la
región veamos entonces el número de
personas que han recibido al menos una
de las dosis de algunas de las vacunas
que están disponibles en el mercado en
esta oportunidad vamos entonces a
centroamérica y comenzamos de norte a
sur con guatemala que cierra la semana
con 604 mil 173 personas con al menos
una dosis el salvador ya alcanzó un
millón 41 personas
honduras 430 mil 859 personas
nicaragua no tiene cifras actualizadas
desde el 21 de mayo por eso no podemos
darles un número específico costa rica
está igual que el salvador 1.42 millones
de personas y cerramos con panamá
llega ya a 891 mil 151 personas
solamente les dejo este dato el 21.1 por
ciento de la población mundial ha
recibido al menos una de las dosis de
estas vacunas
cambiamos de tema esta semana superior
lamentablemente la cifra de 600.000
muertos estamos hablando de eeuu así lo
reporta el conteo que tiene la
universidad johns hopkins por este
motivo los integrantes del congreso en
la ciudad de washington rindieron un
homenaje por supuesto a los fallecidos
esto mientras unos estados como
california comienzan la apertura de la
vida social y comercial y también nueva
york celebró el regreso de la normalidad
de ams
un homenaje a las casi 600 mil víctimas
mortales que deja el kobe 19 en eeuu
desde el inicio de la pandemia
un grupo de líderes del congreso
estadounidenses se reunió a las afueras
del capitolio para recordarlos y
honrarlos con un minuto de silencio la
cifra total de muertos por el virus en
el país es igual a la cantidad de
estadounidenses que murieron de cáncer
en 2019 y mucho mayor al número de
habitantes de ciudades como miami
atlanta durante su visita a europa el
presidente joe biden reconoció este hito
sombrío y siguió instando a los
estadounidenses a vacunarse contra el
kobe 19 a pesar de que el número de
muertes diarias ha disminuido
drásticamente y en medio del
escepticismo de un gran número de
ciudadanos
por eso les sigo diciendo a eeuu si no
se han vacunado vacunen se vacunen ce lo
antes posible tenemos muchas vacunas en
muchos sitios tenemos más trabajo por
hacer para vencer este virus y ahora no
es el momento de bajar la guardia así
que por favor vacunarse ya hemos tenido
suficiente dolor
de acuerdo con el centro para el control
y prevención de enfermedades el 43 7%
del total de la población ha sido
completamente inoculada mientras que el
52% ha recibido al menos una dosis la
alta reserva de vacunas en eeuu ha
llevado a ciudadanos de países de
américa latina' a visitar el país para
aplicársela la mayoría de las
restricciones se han levantado en toda
la unión americana entre ellas el uso
obligatorio de mascarillas y se espera
que eeuu vuelva a la normalidad para el
4 de julio el día de su independencia
una fecha para la cual el país comenzará
a independizarse del virus según lo
prometido por el mismo baile y
brevemente otras noticias noticias
positivas destacadas también esta semana
y comenzamos en cuba' este país comenzó
con ensayos de vacunas en menores de
edad cuba es el único país de américa
latina que está desarrollando su vacuna
propia y comenzará a realizar ensayos en
menores de los 3 a los 18 años con
autorización de sus padres en perú el
ministro de salud óscar ugarte informó
que la segunda ola de contagio de la
pandemia está en descenso cerca de 2
millones
zona se han recibido ya las dos dosis de
vacunas contra el joven 19 y méxico
destino 1.35 millones de dosis de la
vacuna de johnson y johnson donadas por
eeuu para acelerar la vacunación en el
estado de baja california todo esto con
miras a reabrir la frontera común que
está cerrada a viajes no esenciales
desde hace 15 meses baja california es
el primer estado de mexico con
vacunación universal habilitada para
cualquier persona que sea mayor de 18
años
y vamos ahora está ecuador para conocer
detalles de la situación en este país
suramericano en donde el nuevo gobierno
encabezado por guillermo lasso busca
acelerar la vacunación y para ello tiene
una estrategia particular y se ha puesto
metas muy altas generando mucha
expectativa entre los ecuatorianos
gustavo ortega desde quitó nos va a
contar de qué se trata a gustavo como
siempre un gusto saludarlos gracias por
acompañarnos y comenzamos primero dando
una mirada a la situación del país en
general como están avanzando allí los
contagios la cifra de fallecidos y la
ocupación de los hospitales
hola qué tal santiago escobar
experimentas señales alentadoras en la
reducción de la realidad y los casos
positivos de contagio de kobe 19 has ido
al celular una ministra de salud durante
una rueda de prensa recientemente según
cifras oficiales había una proyección de
mortalidad para terminar el mes de julio
con 15.000 fallecidos si no se tomaban
medidas en el país andino a pesar que la
presión bajo se registraron 13 mil
personas fallecidas por kobe 19 en las
últimas dos semanas en este país a
fiestas clandestinas el irrespeto a la
normativa de cirugía sanitaria continúa
siendo una de las principales
preocupaciones de las autoridades para
controlar así los contagios ecuador
exporta la conciencia ciudadana en medio
de un cansancio la ciudadanía por la
reactivación económica el nuevo gobierno
se ha tomado muy en serio la meta de
vacunar a 9 millones de personas en los
primeros 100 días de gobierno pero la
ministra del ramo reconoció que el
sistema de salud está en emergencia en
este país la gente así le ha dado una
oportunidad el gou mandatario que los 24
días que lleva de gestión maneja mayor
popularidad histórica de un presidente
en este país que supera el 70 por ciento
de aceptación un reto en medio de los
contagios que se acerquen a los 500 mil
casos confirmados
en ecuador
gustavo la vacunación es una prioridad
para el gobierno del presidente lazo
pero la vacunación está avanzando muy
lentamente y ecuador- ha tenido muchos
problemas para acceder a los lotes de
dosis de vacunas incluso algunas de
ellas se han demorado qué estrategias
está planteando entonces el gobierno
para acelerar la vacunación y
garantizarle la inoculación a los
ecuatorianos
bueno el plan de vacunación del nuevo
gobierno de guillermo lasso es su
principal oferta de campaña y el
antecedido sobre todo por el fracaso del
gobierno de lenin moreno que no termino
de vacunar al personal de salud ni a los
adultos mayores con apenas 2 millones de
personas vacunadas en un poco más de 4
meses desde el 21 de enero pasado hasta
el 23 de mayo reciente un nuevo problema
por nación que en 24 días de gestión ya
está próxima superar esta cifra de
personas inoculadas con lo que han
denominado la diplomacia las vacunas sin
cuestionar por ideologías políticas a la
hora de adquirir nuevas dosis el
principal clamor de los especialistas en
este país mientras que el gobierno
anuncia continuamente la llegada de
vacunas rusas y chinas por ejemplo
mientras que las demandas se van
exigiendo y van llegando poco a poco si
las vacunas un nuevo plan de vacunación
que utiliza el padrón electoral y los
centros de votación para asignar citas
de vacunación por fases y cronogramas
según las prioridades y las edades pero
las largas filas de personas en
madrugando alguna de red de su
organización todavía se puede observar
en los centros de vacunación pero en los
últimos días el gobierno nacional ha
alertado que la meta podría variar según
la disponibilidad de las vacunas
y exhortó a no exigir vacunas en
particular y aceptar para que estén
disponibles los distintos gremios
profesionales estaban bien exigen
prioridad para ser vacunados en
principio gustavo hablemos ahora de la
apertura el posible regreso al trabajo
presencial a las clases presenciales
también un posible retorno de la vida
social y de la vida cultural todo esto
con ánimo de que los ecuatorianos puedan
un poco respirar y llevar una vida un
poco más parecida a la que tenían antes
del inicio de la pandemia
pero a pesar que se se anunció una
disminución de contagios la demanda de
unidades de cuidados intensivos se
mantiene pero el gobierno se ha trazado
la reactivación económica como otro
frente de trabajo y nuevas medidas es
por eso que desde el primero de julio se
anunció el retorno progresivo y
presencial hacia los lugares de trabajo
también se autorizó el retorno de las
plenarias de la asamblea nacional de
manera presencial con la asistencia de
los parlamentarios también existe un
plan de retorno progresivo de las clases
presenciales en 1300 escuelas un poco
más de 30 universidades otro plan es la
reactivación económica de la pintura que
ha tenido pérdidas superiores a los 200
millones de dólares durante la
paralización por la pandemia es por eso
que el ministerio de salud y el
ministerio de cultura- adelanta en lo
que han llamado las mingas por la
cultura donde artistas músicos
bailarines entre otros realizan
presentaciones culturales en los centros
de vacunación para crear momentos de
esparcimiento y generar la activación
laboral de los gestores culturales en
medio de las largas esperas que deben
sobrellevar las personas cambiando el
tema y finalmente el presidente
guillermo lasso se someterá a una
intervención quirúrgica en la médula
espinal en los eeuu
en el país desde el 20 hasta el 30 de
junio para someterse a una intervención
considerada de mediana complejidad
gustavo pues completo reporte desde
quitó sobre el panorama de la pandemia
en ecuador muchas gracias por habernos
acompañado en el programa vamos a ver
ahora más cifras con respecto al
acumulado de casos confirmados de kobe
19 según el conteo de la universidad
johns hopkins vamos a comenzar este
recorrido en américa del sur en
argentina en donde ya hay más de 4
millones 222 mil personas contagiadas
con kobe 19 las víctimas mortales ya
superan las 87 mil en chile allí hay más
de un millón 500 5.000 casos confirmados
y los fallecidos superan los 31 mil 200
en bolivia superó los 417 mil casos y
allí han perdido la vida más de 15 mil
900 personas y el vecino paraguay
allí los casos superan de los 401 mil y
las víctimas superan los 11 mil 200
vamos a cerrar entonces en uruguay en
donde hay más de 348 mil casos y las
víctimas ya superan los cinco mil cien
y finalmente brasil fue elegida como la
sede alterna de la copa américa que
estaba prevista para ser realizada en
conjunto entre colombia y argentina que
hacen frente a un pico de contagio de
kobe 19 que no da tregua bueno brasil
tampoco está escapando a la difícil
situación sanitaria siendo el tercer
país con más casos en el mundo con más
de 17 millones de personas contagiadas
la pandemia ya comenzó también a
provocar algunos estragos en este evento
deportivo más de 60 casos han sido
reportados desde los directivos hasta
los ayudantes y la copa apenas está
comenzando vamos entonces a la redacción
de france 24 allá está federico cue
barberena periodista de deportes de
nuestra cadena quien debuta hoy en el
programa kobe 19 la semana en américa
federico gracias por acompañarnos hoy en
el programa y qué dicen las autoridades
de la conmebol sobre el avance de la
pandemia al interior de la copa américa
que dice
si pese a la difícil situación sanitaria
en brasil la copa américa sigue su curso
en estadios vacíos y con el respaldo del
gobierno de jair bolsonaro que ha
recibido críticas por acoger la
organización de este torneo el reporte
del ministerio de salud brasileño del
jueves 18 de junio arrojó que hay al
menos 66 casos de kobe 19 relacionados
al certamen sudamericano tras la
realización de seis mil 521 pruebas lo
que representa una positividad del 1 por
ciento de ese número 39 contagios
corresponden a miembros de la
organización del campeonato y árbitros
mientras que 27 positivos involucran a
jugadores o integrantes de los cuerpos
técnicos de las selecciones que
participan entre ellos la delegación más
afectada es la de venezuela que acumuló
tres infecciones tras su llegada a
brasil incluyendo ocho jugadores esto
provocó que afrontará sus primeros dos
encuentros sin varios de sus titulares y
que un grupo adicional de 15 jugadores
viajará para reforzar al plantel
vinotinto la medida fue posible por una
modificación de último momento al
reglamento de la copa dispuesto por
conmebol que permitió la sustitución
ilimitada de jugadores por casos de
coronavirus
otro equipo afectado tuvo cuatro
deportistas contagiados antes de iniciar
el torneo y en las últimas horas sumó
dos más conozcas ribera y jaume cuéllar
chile reportó su primer caso en jueves
aunque no dio a conocer la identidad del
jugador afectado mientras que perú y
colombia también tuvieron positivos en
su staff y federico cuál es la situación
en las ciudades que están siendo sede de
estos partidos y le hago la pregunta
porque cuando fue dado a conocer que
brasil iba a ser la sede de la copa
américa muchos gobernadores de los
estados brasileños dijeron aquí no van a
traer partidos no vamos a dejar usar los
estadios aquí no van a llegar ni
turistas ni jugadores de fútbol para
asistir a estos partidos que dicen
entonces los gobiernos locales
entre las sedes del torneo está en
brasilia goiánia y cuya más ciudades
gobernadas por aliados son de bolsonaro
y que registran una ocupación
hospitalaria por encima del 80% mientras
que en río de janeiro otra de las
anfitrionas los hospitales presentan una
ocupación del 95 por ciento a eso se
suma la poca popularidad del torneo
entre los ciudadanos según una encuesta
de xp y pp antes del inicio del certamen
el 64% de los 1000 consultados está en
contra de la realización de la copa en
brasil todo este contexto opaca un poco
el gran nivel que viene mostrando el
seleccionado anfitrión que se perfila
como gran candidato a repetir el título
conseguido en 2019
federico muchas gracias por este
completo reporte desde las redacciones
de france 24 y gracias por acompañarnos
en el programa la continuación en
nuestra sección en redes veamos otras
noticias destacadas de la semana aquí en
kobe 19 la semana en américa y en esta
oportunidad estaremos enfocados por
supuesto en noticias relacionadas con
los anuncios de la o ms la organización
teme que la pandemia empeore en áfrica
con sólo 1 por ciento de la población
vacunada en ese continente pese a que
los casos están
a nivel global siguen existiendo zonas
donde la pandemia avanza y se estabilizó
con cifras muy altas siendo estas
algunas regiones en américa latina y
áfrica en donde todavía se espera lo
peor de la pandemia y en donde la
vacunación es muy baja ya lo hemos
reportado acá un ejemplo más de la
desigualdad en el reparto de las vacunas
y de la igualdad de coronavirus a la
hora de atacar a los seres humanos
hablemos ahora del anuncio de la
organización panamericana de la salud la
ope s que llevara a cabo una reunión de
preparación con los principales
organismos y también funcionarios
encargados de la respuesta a desastres
en las américas esto ante el riesgo de
huracanes y también fenómenos extremos
de cara a la temporada de huracanes 2021
y la temporada de lluvias la ope s
advirtió que el joven 19 y la probable
devastación provocada por los fuertes
vientos e inundaciones la consecuencia
de este tipo de eventos naturales hace
que la preparación sea necesaria sobre
todo si tenemos en cuenta lo que
padecieron el año pasado colombia
honduras y nicaragua con la temporada de
huracanes y finalizamos en france24
punto con justicia belga obliga a
astrazéneca a cumplir entregas de
vacunas a la unión europea esto luego
después luego de una disputa por los
incumplimientos de la farmacéutica sueco
británica que ahora deberá cumplir con
el calendario de entrega de cerca de 50
millones de dosis de vacunas contra el
jove y 19 antes del 23 de septiembre si
la compañía incumple deberá pagar diez
euros por cada dosis que no sea
entregada a la unión europea
y el tapabocas poco a poco deja de ser
un accesorio obligatorio al menos así
está ocurriendo en israel en donde
solamente debe ser utilizado en espacios
públicos cerrados mientras tanto en
buján en china en donde fue el origen
del hobbit 19 la mascarilla ha sido
dejada completamente de lado por lo
menos así lo evidenció la graduación de
cientos de estudiantes que no la usaron
durante la ceremonia tal parece que las
restricciones comienzan a desaparecer en
algunos lugares del mundo todo lo
contrario en américa latina donde está
sucediendo pues como lo digo lo
contrario algunos lugares han tenido que
reforzar las medidas veamos
es el gran día para estos 11.000
estudiantes todos sin mascarillas en su
ceremonia de graduación en wuhan donde
se originó la pandemia restricciones de
viaje pases de salud y cuarentenas han
permitido a china contener el brote e
hicieron posible ver esta inusual escena
en dinamarca ya no es necesario usar
tapabocas en interiores excepto en el
transporte público la mayoría siente que
se quitó un peso de encima
podemos sonreír con otras personas y
podemos escuchar lo que dice la gente es
increíble
nuestros lentes no se empañan y nuestras
gafas de sol es agradable volver a ver
caras felices
tampoco en israel es obligatorio usar
tapabocas en los interiores excepto en
un hospital o en un asilo de ancianos o
si la persona no se ha vacunado tampoco
en aviones en abril el país se convirtió
en uno de los primeros en deshacerse del
uso obligatorio de mascarillas al aire
libre en latinoamérica por el contrario
chile y argentina- recientemente
volvieron a imponer una serie de
restricciones para contener los
contagios y las jornadas de vacunación
enfrentan retrasos en varios países por
lo que las mascarillas en esta región
continuarán ocultando buenas sonrisas
todavía nos falta un poco en américa
latina' y tenemos que seguir cuidando
nos usando el tapabocas el
distanciamiento social y el lavado de
manos es todo por el momento aquí en
kobe 19 la semana en américa nos vemos
la próxima semana con otras noticias
destacadas de nuestro continente
relacionadas con la pandemia pueden
seguir más detalles en france 24 punto
consiga con nosotros hasta pronto
[Música]